hello how are you greetings even my
jaramillo with his brief informative for
today monday june 21 5 mobile homes
ended up destroyed after a fire
occurred in the southwest of las vegas
several people were left homeless
because of this incident this started
around 11 o'clock  At night in
Altavista I'm leaving a park located in
Güemes Springs admits parkway firefighters
said that some winds complicated
the situation since the fire spread
to other units the red cross and the
salvation army are
assisting people who lost their homes
for another
The Las Vegas Metropolitan Police Department is
on the trail of a gunman after
a fatal shooting occurred in the
Southwest Valley. This incident was at the
Sanchez Motel near Boulder Highway and
Tropicana a little after
9 a.m. Detectives say that  two people
who lived there began to argue
both had weapons and the two unleashed
the shooting one re  He was shot and
the other died fled the scene
Anyone with information
please contact stop the crime at 702 3
855 5.55
Continue at the clinics to receive
the coronavirus vaccine These are
the ones for the week there will be a morning inside
the consulate  Mexican from Las Vegas
tomorrow and on Wednesday they will be offering
the vaccine at the high school and at the end and
at the fire station number 103 on
Thursday they will give the vaccine at the
Trinity United Church also on Thursday and on
Friday they will be distributing these at
the school course in  yungay innobasque and
jan hájek no appointment needed
and now we move on to the
weather forecast a sunny day is expected with winds
up to 30 miles per hour
temperatures will be around 108
degrees for tomorrow more wind and
temperatures will start to drop but it
won't be  For the long term, have a good day,
I am Sal y Jaramillo and this was your
brief informative for Disney in Spanish
[Music]